you hear it on the news all the time if
you can help please call police
well in this case metro police says they
really are at a dead end it is the
murder
of kamiah bird back in september she was
shot while she was driving home from
work on i-15
homicide detectives are now providing
some exclusive new video in the case
hoping someone knows something they
don't
[Applause]
she was beautiful
just a beautiful young woman kamiah bird
was generous
she loved her family loved to help
others and adore
traveling she was
fearless on september 16 2020
bird was thinking of leaving las vegas
in her job at a downtown casino
her mother gloria thinks she may have
moved back to her hometown spokane
washington
in one cruel flash it was over somebody
like it was like your
heart is just gone it feels
strange because we weren't there
you may remember the case i-15 at
flamingo was closed for most of that
september day
as detectives tried to figure out what
happened how a woman driving home from
work could be shot and killed on the
freeway
we do not have a suspect we don't have a
suspect vehicle
and we need help on this case lieutenant
ray spencer leads metro police's
homicide unit
he says his team has chased all the
possible leads in the case
anyone who might have wanted kamiyah
bird dead the case is not much farther
than where
we were back in september so what you're
going to
see now for the first time metro police
are sharing these surveillance
videos of what happened around midnight
september 16th
the cars are very blurry okay we're
tracking headlights we're tracking tail
lights these are the best views from
hundreds of hours of video
this is going to be the victim's car
notice how she stops
that's when detectives believe bird was
shot on the eastbound flamingo off ramp
30 seconds later it starts veering back
onto the highway
where it was hit by a passing car these
are all potential suspects now
lieutenant spencer says metro is very
interested in this
speeding car which was in line with bird
right before she abruptly stopped
detectives just can't tell what it is
it's got to be
just a random shooting that she just
happened to be at the absolute wrong
place at the wrong time
even if lieutenant spencer had an answer
in this case
gloria byrd knows her truth to me
justice would be
my daughter still here you know my
daughter would be here and i could
talk to her and call her or see her
sometimes and
hug her that's not going to happen
now lieutenant spencer acknowledges that
surveillance video it's not
great obviously it was dark however he
hopes that at least highlighting the
case again
will help find a suspect meanwhile
bird's cousin has set up a gofundme page
they're going to try and get the word
out about the case again
we will have a link to that later on
this morning at 8 news now dot com